instead of saying um
world war three is coming we'll do this
yahoo yahoo.com says american express
follows visa and mastercard in exiting
russia so now amex visa mastercard and
paypal are all shutting down services in
russia in response russia is announcing
they'll be partnering with chinese union
bank for the mere card network which
does operate many countries so we're now
seeing a fraction between between two
major economic blocks and um no war will
come of this
no no hyperpolarization no conflict
everyone's going to come together and
the competition will be healthy for
everybody russia will eventually come
and shake hands to the west and say
we're all richer and better off for it
and that's what happens oh yeah not fam
yeah
but everybody gets mad when i say this
stuff is escalating into war well i i
yeah they're in denial yeah i know
i i could have told you that having
these big credit card companies exiting
russia
is going to push russia toward china why
wouldn't it like china is very advanced
but hold on but like is it really going
to escalate the conflict between i don't
know if it will but it will ostracize
them from the rest of the west you know
i think the issue is
if there's no tie between
the dragon bear the bricks economic
block
and the western economic blocks
the chance for conflict is greater
because now there's not there's no
cooperation at all the cooperation helps
it's like listen listen let's not go to
war man like i got a big company i'm
buying that new super yacht chill out
man
russia goes to war they invade
and then it's like
what do you do now
now they start seizing super yachts
all these companies are shutting down in
russia and i think it may be in all in
all seriousness i think a lot of
companies expect the united states to be
involved in a war with russia and that's
why this is happening
i think you might be right because
before the show i was like because this
i was a little bit wound up about this
earlier i was like how is it that these
companies can make this unil unilateral
action against russia it's as if they're
independent companies or countries sorry
treating russia as a foreign enemy but
tim was telling me that it's against the
law to do business with these kinds of
enemies
it's complicated but treason is when you
provide
material aid yeah to an enemy of the
united states so specifically if the
united states was at war with russia
and you then traded weapons to russia
you'd be committing treason unless
you're a multinational corporation then
you have no allegiance i
technically that may be true but if
you're operating in the u.s i think the
us is going to be like particularly
brutal yeah like come on like let's be
real if uh someone in the u.s was
actively selling materials to the
taliban the us would would have before
like if we gave them a bunch of weapons
or something no that was obama who did
that yeah well i don't know about the
taliban but isis for sure yeah no yeah
historically when the government does it
they get away with it
henry ford sold
vehicles to the nazis for years before
the war yeah leading up to war and then
stopped uh yeah i don't know the actual
when he stopped but i would imagine see
that's i would imagine yeah during the
year that's the thing i'm looking at i'm
like why are all these companies are
they really virtue signaling or are they
concerned that if war breaks out it will
be difficult for them to immediately
sever ties and they don't want to be on
the hook in any way i don't think like
right now if the us is like we hereby
declare well it's joe biden so he'd be
like come on man we're declaring russia
i don't well actually he can't do it
because it's congress yeah right right
but you know i don't know he might and
then they might be like no joe stop you
can't do that
uh
i don't think they're gonna start
arresting executives from these big
companies because they're operating in
russia they would be like you have one
week to cease all operations but it is
disconcerting because one could
certainly lead to the other
and i'm wondering if these companies
cutting off from russia they're they're
they're washing their hands of this
economic you know i'm not like russia's
the biggest part of the economy of the
world or anything but they're certainly
cutting themselves off for a major
source of revenue yeah absolutely i
wonder if they're they're they're
worried that war well maybe it's simple
maybe i don't overthink it maybe they
just fear war might break out between us
and them and so better safe than sorry
it's very confusing to me because it to
me it looks like our country is weakened
so if we were to potentially go to war
with russia i it to me it looks like we
wouldn't lose just based on like how
culture's been kind of going in a
certain direction for like the last
couple of years we don't look very
strong so you're saying we would or
wouldn't lose like i i think we would
well it looks like we would based on how
ours that way it appears that way i
agree with you i have some i have some
feelings that the american military has
some nasty weaponry prepared yeah yeah i
agree with you i hope you're right is
this a poker game like they're making us
look weak yeah
yeah that's right when you are strong
you make your opponent look weak but um
i think the reason the u.s could lose
well i should i don't know if i agree
with you that they would but could
because we're so divided with gas prices
reaching record highs yo we were in
central pa this weekend diesel was like
550
and gas was like 450. yep crazy
so when you see that
we're already in this hyper-polarized
country where everyone's still
constantly fighting
you've got the establishment pushing
their narrative saying trumpers are evil
and all this stuff
one of the things that precipitates
civil war is rising cost of food
wheat is up 68
that freaked me out there's this viral
tweet where someone was like this is not
oil or a meme stock this is wheat and
it's like going straight and then spikes
which suggests
the demand
the expectation is supply will not meet
demand so buy it you know they're buying
it now expecting the price to skyrocket
causing the price to skyrocket
that's scary because foods food's
already insanely expensive yep
going yeah in fl and and now get this
with russia and the u.s at odds and you
know look visa and mastercard so what
what happens when we stop importing
fertilizer from russia which we are a
major
importer of i'm sorry did i say expert
what happens when we start we stop
importing fertilizer from russia right
food's gone yep so i'm i'm thinking you
know covid may have been in terms of
food shortages a hiccup compared to what
we see now
food prices through the roof food
shortages and gas shortages and gas
prices and you've got a recipe for
disaster people are going to start
screaming for donald trump because
they're gonna say trump did not get us
into any new wars gas prices were low
food was abundant unemployment was low
i'd rather have the president who says
no war and fix america than joe biden
and his international whatever i feel
like trump sailed us into the iceberg
and then biden got on board and took
control
how did trump was just printing they
were just the economy was like the best
it's ever been we just keep just the
debt just keeps going up and up and up
and up and he's
didn't didn't repeal the federal reserve
he he had john bolton on board his
sister got him to bomb syria like it's
just a just his status quo here's his
daughter status quo
status quo you could say that uh obama
did that and trump this whole time none
of them changed course they all took
chance and none of them have done it the
federal reserve is sinking us listen
listen
if you're if you've ever been on a
cruise ship no those things are so
impossible to move so let's say you're
on this cruise ship that's been sailing
this way for 60 years
and you get four years to try and turn
it around and you make some turns and
all of a sudden the economy is doing
better you get your troops out of
afghanistan trump did some stuff also if
he tries to turn the ship they're gonna
they got guns and they're like don't
turn the ship sir right that i agree
with yeah so i do feel like trump did
what he could i do feel like trump in
many ways is kind of a bad dude i think
he's a generous guy you hear the stories
about how he's giving his staff all this
money i've heard stories directly from
people who work at his hotel like he
just gives 100 bills yeah so there's
good things there's bad things about him
i think he's kind of an arrogant dude
but i think he did some good things that
he genuinely wanted to you know help
this country the problem is joe biden
gets right back in and course corrects
and then we go sailing you know
headfirst into ukraine how is it this is
amazing the clinton global initiative is
coming back have you heard this what
yeah no five year hiatus okay under
donald trump
yeah oh my gosh is that a bad thing i'm
looking at you guys and not sure
it's not that clinton's come on it's not
it's not that in my opinion
we can talk about the global initiative
or whatever their operation is it's
about that when hillary clinton loses
it goes defunct
and then donald trump comes in joe biden
comes back in and now they're kicking
everything back up it's that when donald
trump gets elected no war in ukraine we
had the eastern separatists we had the
2014 regime change in ukraine we then
had eastern separatist conflict since
then but vladimir putin did not invade
ukraine during trump's presidency what
the establishment says the left democrat
types is that oh because trump was
deferential to putin and giving him what
he wants and i'm like that's kind of an
extreme way of saying donald trump
avoided a war in europe which um if
we're trying to avoid world war iii
then i don't necessarily see anything
wrong with what trump was doing if it
prevented war you know i'll put it this
way when they say that i'm like so
you're saying that everything we're
seeing now in ukraine could have been
prevented that there was something that
you thought was worth
all of this death and destruction that's
kind of crazy to me because under trump
we didn't have that but as soon as biden
comes in all of a sudden putin's like
it's time to go i think the issue is the
democratic agenda clearly at odds with
russia clearly trying to pressure use
nato influence to pressure russia and
put them in a continually weaker
position antagonizing putin which is
which is bad because it got nuclear
weapons
donald trump wasn't doing that donald
trump often said oh he's a powerful guy
man you gotta watch out because he
understood russia was but still you know
avoiding war um
a good thing
now we're at the point where vladimir
putin not only sees the return of the
democrat agenda but ex but an extremely
weak president
well it's funny how the playbook has
flipped here because i remember in the
early 2000s it was the democrats who are
constantly being accused of being weak
on terrorism whenever they tried to take
any measure that would prevent warfare
and now because trump got through four
years without starting a new war and
because we didn't end up having
tensions escalate with russia we're told
it's because he was weak by by the same
people who were accused of weakness you
know 15 20 years ago wow
it's kind of crazy to think
that the view who was it was like dave
was it david from i don't want to accuse
the wrong person
but to be like donald trump was was
appeasing putin that's why he didn't
invade and i'm like didn't he
donald trump prevented a war with russia
yeah that's all i'm hearing yeah i'm
like okay that's kind of a good thing
well and we were talking about this the
other day i'm not sure if this is just a
trump quote that we haven't verified but
didn't he say that he threatened putin
he said if you invade ukraine we will
bomb moscow
yeah the original story was that he said
to putin if you take ukraine i'll hit
moscow but then trump himself i guess
came out
in fact check me on this one because i
saw a story and he was like i told putin
i'd nuke moscow
geez
that's not good i don't i don't i don't
like hearing those stories i mean i hear
you but that's definitely not
appeasement for sure yeah and along
those lines i looked up if uh ted turner
was involved with the georgia guys
stones there's no evidence it's
completely anonymous who did those
things but i don't know why his name's
wrapped around you know talking about
this democratic problem that we have
this liberal economic order-ish problem
i looked up american express and who
owns it let's do some math so vanguard
blackrock and state street own about
17 of of american express but berkshire
hathaway owns 20 of american express who
owns berkshire hathaway oh twenty
percent of berkshire hathaway is owned
by vanguard blackrock and state street
huh so they own companies that own
companies that they also own
so that's not sketchy no that's uh that
seems perfectly totally it's beyond
american democracy it's beyond liberal
and and conservative at this point it's
an economic overthrow it's it's they've
been doing it so subtly but it's so
obvious now yeah
i just don't know who they are
the ceos of these companies maybe look
look it goes beyond it's it's beyond the
front man you do deep dive in where's
the money at where's that what's up the
panama papers oh there you go blow them
open yeah let's go wasn't there like a
second release yeah i heard something
just came out recently about it recently
i wasn't the journalist
uh killed yeah he was investigating it's
like the most dangerous thing a rabbit
hole on earth is but i mean you guys
remember when that one dude who had that
island with little girls on it yeah
and then the guy who was working with
them like also died in his
remember and then and then the lady who
worked with them got convicted
of trafficking minors but like to who we
don't know
so like to know what we we we can prove
that you were doing this and then okay
well hold on proving that they were
doing it means you know
that there was an exchange between two
parties so who's that party involved
okay if you're convicting this woman
maxwell
that means
you know that other people were
involved uh-huh you know what man
conspiracy it's consistently i think of
uh dantone from the french revolution
who was eventually executed by his
partner robespierre uh and as he was
being executed up in the court he said
better to have been a poor farmer than
to meddle in the politics of man and i
think this now as we're doing this show
if i start naming names and really going
deep on the panama papers and seeing
that's like putting a target on my face
oh yeah why do we wake up and like ian's
just not here i don't want to be i don't
want to do that but like if i don't
address this stuff how do you how do you
fix earth and and help humans you just
got to let them like fry themselves and
then regrow from the ashes i don't want
to do that it's what they think they're
doing
one day we all come back on the show and
there's like a guy who looks like ian
but it's not even actually and he's like
hello friends i am ian crossland and
we're like i'm not even this guy i'm not
a fed i do not work with the world
economic forum
i think maybe culture
culture and business you know is the way
to to try to try and fix earth like
elon's building satellite internet that
that's a good start yeah um culture you
make people laugh with movies that's a
good start didn't they actually reach
out to his uh internet service the they
did
yeah they wanted they wanted starlink to
block russia and he was like nah he said
about first speech first amendment
absolutist sorry that wasn't the only
thing they did they also asked tess that
they also asked elon musk to shut down
tesla vehicles in russia
and he's like
no absolutely not i'm like if this was
any other ceo you have no guarantee
first of all isn't that a core reason
why i don't want to get an extra car
yeah i was like no i'm out on that one
for sure that was crazy that was like
it's just some social justice warriors
on twitter so it's like a serious thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there
you